the Fathers of the field who is going to
tell us about reflection positivity and
its relationship to zeroes oh thanks
very much thanks for the invitation
thanks for the honor of the first
speaker and I didn't say anything about
relation compliment okay
yes a compliment is a relation so this
is going to be a mini course on
reflection positivity that's because I
haven't done anything about polynomials
for many years so this is the closest I
could get to the subject of the
conference and here I've listed a whole
lot of people that over the years I've
worked with on this subject which
developed took time a lot of people
contributed ideas so I want to make sure
that you know I didn't do this all by
myself
of course she wouldn't but just in case
so this is the what should I say the the
political part so to speak know the
celebrated liang circle theorem for the
zeroes of the ferromagnetic easing model
which had a big impact in his day I
remember this very well and it's very
important generalization by asan Hall I
don't know how many of you have read I
so know but he was the one who really
understood what was going on and was
able thereby to generalize it to quantum
mechanics to the Heisenberg model and
things like that instead of the usual
easing model how many people have read
arsenal how many people have heard of us
ah no oh great okay unfortunately he
very long but he contributed a lot but
then there were many many other people
who contributed to this subject you all
know that I won't list names and
contributed a great deal to our
understanding of phase transitions
when it works which it doesn't often but
when it does it's very important but
this title of the paper in which this
was announced by Lin yang was called the
statistical theory of phase transitions
and the first remark is that it mostly
led to a theory of the absence of phases
namely it's the its if it works it tells
you that in this region over here in the
complex plane we're not going to have
anything funny happen so that's a theory
of non phase transitions and if
something does happen well it'll happen
over here and so as I said here its main
use mathematically at least was to show
that a certain region in the complex
plane of parameter space was free of
zeros of the partition function and
hence free of any singularity of its
logarithm Oh free energy and by the way
I thought I'd put in a little commercial
for myself and David well who just
appeared namely if you want to see what
you can say about an antiferromagnet I
don't know if this is well-known or not
but for an antiferromagnet things are
very different they don't why on the
unit circle and there's not much you can
say but what you can say is that in this
paper if you want to take a look at it's
kind of interesting because it uses the
theory of several complex variables in a
fundamental way okay
now one way to prove the existence of
phase transitions is to prove that in
one region of parameter space no long
range order appears they're just
long-range orders the key word here and
in another region there of parameter
space there is long-range order so it
either is or isn't it's a two valued
statement so somewhere in between
something funny must have happened that
means there's a phase transition so if
you can show this that in one region
this no long-range order and another
region there is you're in business now
it's usually quite easy to prove the
existence of long-range order say at
high temperature for example of
temperature as a parameter and you do
this by perturbations here in cluster
expansion all kinds of ways to do it
there's a whole industry connected with
that but usually it's just perturbation
theory so we have this region systems
straightened out another example would
be large magnetic fields or small
magnetic fields the hard part is to
prove that long-range order exists when
the parameter in question is
sufficiently large the parameter in this
case would be one over the temperature
beta one of the great historical
mistakes of all times was too cold when
it's cold called this low temperature
and really is how should we call it high
something and it's hot it's low
something that was dramatic mistake this
alone
somebody fairly recently in the
nineteenth century or that sort of the
common man understood that there was a
continuum between cold and hot in
weather I used to think well there's
cold in his heart
the cold comes in the door or the hot
come anyway now one of the ways to prove
the existence of long-range order is to
use reflection positivity now I'm going
to assume this is going to be very light
talk not many equations in fact no
equations at all so to speak almost and
so this is a talk mainly for people who
don't know what this is and I will try
to explain what it is and how it works
the details are for another day and
historically speaking at least that I
know of it starts with Osterwalder
Estrada in 1973 who used this to prove
something about quantum field theory now
I should tell you that there are several
kinds of reflection positivity
and there are several ways in which it
or that it them they can be applied and
the one I want to talk about today is to
prove a phase transition for a
particular kind of dimer system but
that'll come at the end of the talk so
first I'm going to talk just about what
it is at least the kind that I'm talking
about okay now I'm going to begin with a
fun topic that has nothing to do much to
do with statistical mechanics although
it's very important in some some areas
of the quantum many-body problem and
this is sort of bait for the analysts in
the audience who like potential theory
if you don't like potential theory or
don't know anything about it forget it
this is all the two slides so let me
remind you about potential theory you
take the inverse of the laplacian which
is a kernel one over X minus y
and three dimensions at least and so you
apply this to a function on r3 and you
integrate and then you integrate it
against another function so this is a
quadratic form and this kernel is
positive definite which means that this
quantity is always positive if F and G
are the same function now that's fine
but that's not what I'm talking about
I'm not talking about this positivity
I'm going to talk about another
positivity then the positivity that I
want to talk about is the following so
we take a plane in r3 any plane you like
is a plane and you take a function f
which is supported on the left half
space so here's a plane F is supported
over here okay and and you take another
function which is supported on the right
half it's not the same function and then
they don't but one is this they have
supports on one or the other side of the
plane and I want to take F to be the guy
on the left and G to be the one
supported on the right so this business
object here has no right to be positive
doing that it's two different functions
want to support it and want to support
it there however it turns out sorry
there is a positivity nevertheless and
that positivity involves an inversion so
I can identify the left half with the
right half just by the usual way you
just say if it's the Z is the coordinate
perpendicular to the plane you just
reflects through Z so we say that theta
on a function on the right is a function
on the left by inversion and I can look
at the energy when this guy is is the
reflection of that
and that is positive now most potential
theorists as far as I know don't know
this fact you know the first fact but
not this fact it's not difficult to
prove using Fourier transform
so if once again if this is the
reflection of that is positive so that
sets up a correspondence between left
and right for any plane anywhere and
this fact is called reflection
positivity
it induces an inner product between the
opposite sides of any plane any plant
they might call it the narcissus effect
why because this is closely related to
the fact that when you look at yourself
in the mirror you appear to be on the
other side of the plane and the other
side in the mirror right
it is what narcissus would have called
reflection positivity if he had known
about it so now what good is this
positivity what's it good for
suppose we want to maximize the energy
that with rechannel energy efforts on
any function and there's some domain and
suppose this domain that we're
interested in in r3 suppose it can be
bisected by a plane which is symmetric
with as far as the geometry is concerned
so for example think of a cube well
Kuban i guess i will do it then the
function that and you're trying to
maximize some function l of the function
f which i don't write down explicitly
for example some LP norm or whatever and
the thing that connects the function for
different points is this Coulomb energy
e now you would like to know that if
there's a Maximizer for this problem
that you're looking at you would like to
know that the Maximizer has the same
symmetry as the problem you see not
every symmetric problem ends up with the
symmetric maximizes we all know but on
the other hand using reflection
positivity which of course work the the
the LP norm condition that you put on is
symmetric but I take that for granted
then by Cauchy Schwartz if I take any
function write it as the left piece and
a right
with respect to this plane then I easily
conclude that twice he of the F in its
reflection the left part in the right
part squared is less than the energy for
the left part and the reflection of the
left part plus the reflection of the
right part and the right part that's
what I get out of it
anytime you have a quadratic with the
positivity who end up with Schwarz
inequality there it is and so this tells
you that one of these two choices is
going to do better than that choice at
least one
because this this guy is less than the
maximum of those two guys there's a
square is less than the product okay so
reflection positivity is a good way to
tell us that the answer has to be
symmetric now this is of great use in
statistical mechanics not the Coulomb
problem in general but in general this
thing this kind of inequality is going
to be very useful that we will say okay
is this clear to everybody that if you
have a kind of positivity for a plane
then what you do on the left is what you
want to do on the right maximum and of
course if we're trying to do
minimization then if the if this gadget
has a minus sign in front of it then you
do it the other way around
now think let's press our luck think of
periodically stacked reflection planes
in r3 so I mentioned someplace like this
an infinite sandwich and equally spaced
and now we want to maximize now the
total Coulomb energy we can use this
reflection trick so you take one of the
planes you say well what I'm looking for
will be we reflect a symmetric which
reflects with respect to reflection in
that plane by the reflection positivity
then having got that I now take the next
plane and say well it has to be
symmetric with respect to that as well
for the same reason and then with
respect to that guy as well for the same
reason so I end up with a Maximizer that
is not only reflection positive with
respect to one plane but with all of
them so it's periodic and if it also
works in this direction then I can end
up with cubes I'm being very schematic
about this I mean but you have to fill
in the details by yourself okay but this
is an amazing fact you can just apply
reflections all over and over and over
again and you end up with the periodic
structure
next so summary so far we have learned
that there can be interactions with the
property that they prefer to have states
that are symmetric with respect to
planes such interactions are called
reflection positive there are also
systems that prefer anti symmetry for
example the easing anti ferromagnetic
antiferromagnet that would like if you
reflect you want to have the opposite of
what you have done here up here and that
that's like a reflection positive but
with a minus sign we still call a
reflection positive we can also call it
reflection negative lots of words are
used so for example if you instead of
the laplacian is minus the laplacian is
just the laplacian in verse but without
the minus sign so that would be
reflection negative
now if this is still unclear I will now
discuss the leasing model ferromagnetic
EC model so the energy is everybody
knows his sis J nearest neighbors on
some lattice with a minus sign which
means that everybody wants to be
parallel and this Hamiltonian is of
course reflection positive that is it
perfect whatever you do on the Left
however complicated you want to do on
the right is a whoops I went in the
wrong direction
let me just temporarily go forward so
here's something on the right it's not
it's just ran though it is random and
here's something random on the left
there's some energy I can lower the
energy by taking either this and its
reflection over here
whatever this may be or the other way
around you select this over here one or
the other will have a lower energy than
what stands here okay and for the
antiferromagnet there's a minus sign
which means that whatever you do on on
the right you want to do - it on the
left
turn it over and put - in and that tells
you that in this way you build up again
reflections this way and reflections
this way you end up with the periodic
structure except the periodic means plus
minus plus minus plus minus plus period
- in the usual technical sense now you
might worry it's the next slide you
might worry that about the following
fact that I can do this only once and
cannot reflect here why because there's
a boundary I just have to take that into
account so what do I do I really want to
reflect here and use the argument again
but I can't so what do I do I wrap this
on it Taurus well I factor first on a
cylinder if I'm days that's it this way
and then I wrap down onto this so I get
it Taurus and for a very big system you
can easily prove that doesn't matter so
now I can reflect the reflection cuts
the cylinder into two pieces so there
are two cuts there's one cut here and
one cut there if you really want to
think about it
now well so what
anybody can see this all we need visit
bipartite graph we're sort of proving
the obvious what good is it well because
now we can say something about
correlations it's not so obvious
correlations are the new word because I
want to prove that if the interaction is
strong enough then I'm going to get
long-range order this is quite a
different story in so here's a partition
function the expectation value of any
function is the close to sum over the
spins times this function of the spins
time sir
e to the minus the energy divided by the
temperature so for low temperature that
is when this 1 over T is big we expect
to get something interesting and so we
pick one of the any plane you like and
we look at F which lives on the left and
depends only on the spins on the left
and we can let G depend on the spins on
the right and we can define theta F to
be the reflection of F and so on and so
on
and we get an inner product in this way
and the way I just explained just needed
that positivity that one that the energy
is best when they're the same on left
and right that's the only thing I've
used and it's positive or in this case
the energy is negative because the
partition function is 8 the exponential
is positive and this reflection
positivity of functions now is a direct
consequence of the reflection positivity
of the Hamiltonian
reflection positivity of the hamiltonian
Gibbs when you put it in the exponent
and look at expectations how does it
tells you something about functions now
it's this point that gets very sticky if
you try to do this in quantum mechanics
the the the the reflection positivity of
the hamiltonian you cannot split this
exponential into two pieces in quantum
mechanics which is what I've sort of
been doing but I'm telling you it's
there are commutator is to worry about
all kinds of complicated things but you
can do it but it's not easy so let's ask
a specific question let take a projector
onto for each vertex will define the the
projector which is plus 1 when the spins
at the vertex I this is right and one of
its nearest neighbors is our opposite
that's that's a bad case and that it's
plus minus or minus plus or zero
otherwise and I is some collection of
vertices any collection you want which I
call capital I and I take the product of
those guys again in quantum mechanics we
have to worry a little bit and we want
to find an upper bound on the expected
value of this bad guy so this this says
what does it say you're looking for the
probability that all the vertices in
this collection I that you've picked out
are bad in a configuration
okay you'd like to estimate that so here
I have a bunch of vertices all over the
place and I want the universal bound on
the probability that every one of them
is bad
that's the good interesting and we want
to show that for small enough T that we
can do this in a useful way but it's
unlikely to find mismatched spins on I
so we asked the we asked the question
which set I which collection if I will
maximize this one over I the volume of I
the number of points and I times the
logarithm of the expectation so I could
be one point it could be no well it
can't be none right one point two points
10 points I didn't know maybe the whole
thing I'm looking at the expected value
of the energy
maybe wait a minute I guess I don't want
the large and well I do want the log
sorry I want the log because I want the
nth root that's what I want and I would
like this expectation to be something to
the power n where n is the volume of I
no matter where these vertices are in
the world where they're next to each
other what's the worst case so the
probability of finding n mismatched
edges anywhere anywhere for any for any
fixed number n any n is less than e to
the minus n times a where a is some
positive number now I claim if we can
prove that if the interaction
Hamiltonian is or the temperature is
small enough then we can in fact find a
positive a that's Universal by
reflecting over and take it and take
your worst case and reflect it
all right well what so let me repeat
that you want them to know what happens
if I tell you that end points and I and
it's anything you want that there's a
number a so that if you pick any end
points five points or ten points
anywhere there's a universal number so
that the probability that they're bad is
small small in the sense that it's less
than something to the power to the size
of the set you're looking at so the
probability is bounded by e if this's
should be an a so the probability that
that the power is
so it turns out that when the D is Ohno
so let me start at the beginning I
forgot all right now once you know that
fact that's universal thank the piles
argument of 1936 tells you that you will
have long-range order that is if this
guy is mismatched over here that guy
arbitrarily far away is also mismatched
with a probability greater than 1/2 this
guy is good that guy will be good with
the probability greater than 1/2 let's
put it that way
and how do you do that will you say if
that's mismatched and this one isn't
what's going to happen in between there
has to be at least one curve so to speak
running through this lattice where on
one side everybody's has one sign and on
the other side of this curve everybody
has the opposite sign if they have
opposite maybe I should have said that
let's look rather at this guy being plus
and this guy being - let's look at it
that way then there has to be a boundary
where on one side of the boundary it's
all plus and all it's not it's - now we
know what that costs us it costs us the
size of the boundary where how many
boundaries can there be between two
points arbitrarily far away
well you can estimate that that's very
simple geometry
how many boundaries there can be so you
have a competition between e to some
number times the N where n is the size
of the boundary - this a I should have
put an A in there a is now 1 over T I
guess and I can easily make that smaller
than 1/3 by letting T be large enough so
that's the argument of piles now piles
had this argument 1936 but he made a
mistake mistake was he was not able
really rigorously to prove what I just
said that the that there's a universal
number so that the probability is just
that universal number times the size of
the boundary is there other delicate
argument if you have to do it from
scratch and but that was done by
dilution later and as far as I remember
and so that by the time reflection
positivity came along it was well
understood but the point is that this
this result which you get by reflecting
over and over again maybe I should have
said that more explicitly if I have a
mismatch somewhere then the probability
of getting a mismatch next to it the
vertex next to it is a little bit bigger
than 1/2 because of the interaction and
the reflection positivity so I keep
reflecting and the worst case turns out
to be just by reflecting that the worst
case is when every vertex is mismatched
every vertex and then it's easy to
calculate if every vertex is mismatched
that means I've taken the ferromagnet
and made an antiferromagnet out of it
now let's talk about dimers
this is what I put in the abstract so I
may as well talk about it
well everybody here I think knows what
dimers are you take a lattice you put
diamonds off matchings but we're not
talking about perfect matchings now
we're talking about monomer diamond
system so if dimers and we have empty
sites where nothing is but you cannot
put two timers on the same
everybody knows that we also know by
looking at zeros of the polynomial
generated by the dimer fugacity this
polynomial has zeros on the imaginary
axis so when when there are monomers
around nothing can happen and the only
time anything interesting can happen if
you have diamonds is when you have pure
diamond coverings then something can
happen but otherwise you the zeros
prevent anything happening when you have
monomers as well okay
nevertheless I'd like to get something
happening so we're going to invent a
model with interaction so once again I'm
just repeating myself now if you just
have diamonds you can have phase
transitions as you vary the edge weights
of the dimers but otherwise nothing in
terms of phase transitions that was 1971
so in order to or in an effort to get
something interesting for the monomer
diamond system we think of the diamonds
as diatomic molecules and we introduce
an attractive interaction between
neighboring dimers so make it look a
little bit like a easy model now this
was proposed by harmon and myself in
1979 and we gave examples into the Adhan
3d as well of these kinds of
interactions that would induce a phase
transition and more precisely give you
long-range order and therefore induce a
phase transition as I explained before
but for purposes now let me just do the
2d example and that goes as follows now
now you remember that just to remind you
castellane and temporally and Fischer
computed the partition function for the
pure dimer covering and you can do it in
several ways including doing it by the
transfer matrix method they didn't do it
that way
so now we're going to talk about a
non-zero density of monomers which is
not covered by the postulate thankfully
all the transfer matrix matter now
so we're going to introduce an
interaction that gives us a negative
energy which is when two diamonds are
oriented like this
so there's one dimer there's an
otherwise when they like this next or
like that they have an energy
they'd like to be this way negative
energy okay and I'll show you a picture
of that in just a second make it clearer
so these molecules attract each other
but so they do although they attract
each other it's not clear whether this
attraction continues or gets dissipated
that is whether you're going to this you
with low enough temperature that is
strong enough interaction nearest
neighbors will tend to be aligned the
same way that much is clear
but there's that alignment continued
forever and ever and ever one does it
just sort of break and so it turns out
that reflection positivity tells us that
e to the minus HT which is e to the
minus J times the number of edges that
are correctly oriented number of things
like this or like that has we that this
thing has reflection positivity and
therefore eventually long-range order
now let me see here's a picture
so this this was made by Ian Yost it
might go work on this here's what his
picture of a liquid crystal looks like
in the liquid crystals by the way that's
what you see on your television screen
there there are long molecules we just
like to line up in the same direction so
they could just line it as well line up
this way or this way or that way or any
way and here's the thing on a square
lattice so anytime two guys are next to
each other and like to the next to each
other and in the same orientation you
get some negative energy so these are
red Wiggles are the negative energies I
get so to go back again that the
partition the weight is e to the minus
some constant times the number of edges
with correctly oriented diamonds on both
vertices two vertices diamond this way
and a diamond that like that's the
partition function or the Boltzmann
factor and what we're hoping for
what's the reason for this we are hoping
for the following that we will be able
to prove using reflection positivity or
any other means that if you the
temperature is low enough that is if the
interaction is strong enough if it--
conditioned on some dimer being
somewhere for example this one being
like that and I look infinitely far away
on though I look on the moon that I will
see diamonds oriented in the same
direction
what I would like not to see what I
would like not to see if I have I'm
trying to model liquid-crystal I would
not like to see translational order you
see the dimer if I take a vertex over
there and I there's a probability that
if if it's hanging a dimer is hanging
from it that there will be another one
that this timer will be in the same
orientation as the one I pick so
conditioned on over there but it could
be in two places it could be either here
or here in other words I don't want to
see any lattice structure I don't want
to see any translational order I want to
see orientational order but not
translational order I don't want the
diamonds to line up like a checkerboard
that's the characteristic of a liquid
crystal and that's the reason for this
model
so who's speaking because I want to
model a liquid crystal and the liquid
crystal which I just showed you picture
off has the property that it's a liquid
there's no translation it's it's really
a liquid you can smell you know you can
squeeze here when touch screen you can
well leave something we compress and you
see that it's a liquid behind it but the
molecules are lined up but there's no
translational order as in a solid the
only orientational order of the
molecules that's what I would like to
see I'm trying to model it up to this
point there had been no model of any
kind with this phenomenon where you had
the potentiality for two kinds of
long-range order but only one of them
appears
so by the way how am i doing with the
time that another fight tell you okay
good thank you so much okay so we expect
the following what we expect
respect that if the interaction strength
/ the temperature which is what counts
is all small ish that will not be any
kind of long-range order of any kind
he'll just be a jumble if I condition on
a dimer of being over here what goes on
on the moon it's just independent it's
just rare that's what I expect at when J
/ T is small that's easy to prove again
you do some perturbation theory whatever
that's not difficult now we expect that
above a certain critical value of J / T
there will be orientational long-range
order so that means if J / T is big that
if I fix this guy is oriented this way
vertically then I look at the moon and I
look at a dimer on huge thing there will
be one more than 50% chance of the Dymo
over there at that vertex being this way
or this way but not that way now and
okay
yeah so so that's the crystallization
part so if you shine light on it which
is what you do or electric fields or
whatever you'll see things that'll look
it would be visible that there's some
order as you would get in reflection
from a crystal because the diamonds are
oriented in the same direction not
perfectly of course but what we would
like to get see is that for suitable
values of J over T there will not be
translational order that's what we'd
like that so this is hot now this is so
this is the liquid aspect of things
that's why it's called a liquid crystal
now since that time when when this was
introduced other models have appeared
and I'm not going to tell you about them
because that's not purposes talk but
what was done was 98 79 Heilmann I
proved that we did have this long-range
orientational order and again we use
reflection positivity it's obvious that
if a time if you if you draw a plane
through the bonds this z2 you do a plane
that the Orient the interaction is such
that whatever you do on the left you
want to do on the right so give if I
tell you what's on the left and what's
on the right then I the left and its
reflection or right and its reflection
will have a greater probability than the
original thing you gave me that's that's
obvious from the interaction it likes
what if it's if they if it's like this
you want to have that if it's like this
you want to have that and so on that's
clear but that's not quite enough
because of the funny nature of this
thing that what's going on is not just
with one point interacting with another
point that's for the easy model it's
much more complicated it's a whole dimer
interacting with another dimer so the to
do the reflection positivity game you
have to take as the basic unit not a
vertex but a whole square of vertices
and play with that as the unit as it
were so it gets to be a lot more
complicated but it's the same argument
reflection positivity tells you that
eventually the left and the right want
to be the same in this and this sameness
propagates out to infinity if the
temperature is low enough and we did
this in 1979 and then we conjectured
that there would not be any
translational order so this guy out
there is like that but it could as well
be this way
and that took 38 years a lot of people
tried to prove that obviously some
people tried and this was done by ian
Yellen and myself in 2017 and a couple
years ago we did not use for this any
reflection positivity we did not use any
Pyles argument the piles argument was
used in Part B as I explained before but
here not in this work that what did work
was a paragraph C night argument and I
understand somebody's going to talk
about paragraph C now in this conference
that's very nice
so that did work but it's very and if
anybody can find a really neat proof of
this that simpler go ahead because it's
very complicated it's because there are
all kinds of possibilities of the way
these guys link together
I mean it's after all a two dimensional
object now it's not a wonderment
here oh the matsusaki it's one
dimensional not a zero dimensional
object okay so you can look it up in the
archive so let me summarize what I did
when I talk try to explain so I tried to
explain with reflection positivity is
what it's good for and it's the property
of an interacting system in which there
is an involution of some kind
not necessarily pure geometric
reflection for example
you remember at the beginning I talked
about the reflection positivity of the
Coulomb potential
and that whatever charge you put over
here you want to put the same one over
there well there's another involution
you can have with respect to the Coulomb
potential
it's conformal invariant so another kind
of evolution you can have is inversion
in the sphere this was understood by the
ancients right that now the Coulomb
forces work very nicely under inversion
take a sphere and you could invert the
outside to the inside so it turns out
that you can have reflection positivity
for inversion in its fears for the
Coulomb potential this was done by
rupert franken myself so just some kind
of involution and usually we've
associated with reflections in a plane
so that the interaction energy is low it
or sometimes raised when the right side
is reflected the left of I suppose after
making a choice in applying this
repeatedly too many parallel planes one
can prove that the energy minimizer that
has a periodic structure when a
probability measure has this property it
follows that expectations satisfy the
same property and this part is doesn't
is very difficult in quantum mechanics
the second this thing I just mentioned
it can be done in many cases but it's
much harder than in the classical case
because of commutator and so this leads
not only to periodic structures but also
very important to an estimate that the
number the expected expected value of
the number of bad boxes or whatever it
is less than e to the minus some
positive constant times the number of
boxes regardless of where they are
which is kind of quite striking because
you might think that if you if you
nicely sort of combine things in a nice
smooth geometric way maybe it could
become not so improbable but no it's not
true for any number of boxes anywhere
and so when the effective interaction
becomes large when the parameter say
temperature for example is small and
then you apply a piles argument and this
leads to a proof of a phase transition
and with that I say thank you for
listening so it kind of reminds that
what does that cost and up somatization
villians parametric results yes but so
this was first approached to prove that
certain yeah I I've tried as a matter of
fact it's a very good point that you
make in principle it ought to be the
case that reflection positivity would
give you the isoparametric inequality
just keep reflecting and reflecting but
I could never quite make this work there
are technical problems but you you have
a good idea here but some hopes key was
look and carriage it's okay replace
can't oh yeah but yeah maybe right go
ahead
I mean I it's a very very good intuition
this is the way to replace you don't
feel good look at the great these
equations that meant that of some kind
of local carriage because yeah but you
don't need a lot concavity of course so
here's an is an object okay let me do
the following cut it take a plane cut it
into two equal areas which I can do
okay and then I easily see that I could
take the left and reflect it over here
and put the two together that's a
legitimate thing to do with the matches
nicely or the other way around one of
the two choices left left or right right
will have a perimeter that is at least
as small as the one you started with now
you do it with a different direction and
a different direction and the difference
keep doing this all the time splitting
the things so that you have equal areas
on both sides and then reflect over and
over and over again what will you end up
with well unfortunately you can end up
with a disaster we can separate it after
a while this is much time that gets like
the three kids civilization yeah okay so
but all right let's go on anymore
any more questions
that you say anymore about she's in the
continuity case of one sort what is
involved in showing these long range
well you know I cannot in a few words
but it it's I mean the typical situation
is you you whatever you're dealing with
you have to take some plane so there's
an the the energy of the left side and
the energy of the right side which is
well-defined you know it now and then
there's the interaction between the to
some kind of interaction which involves
quantum mechanical operators and you
would like very much to split this right
this is the product of three
Exponential's which of course would not
necessarily be self adjoint anymore
and oh yes so now you then you know not
sure what you've got it at all in any
case it's not right and I mean the trace
of you don't have any nice inequality
for the what we do have one actually but
I don't know for the trace of the
product of three operators and but in
any case you can't split it this way
because of all the commutator is that
are hanging around when you try to do
that and so what you have to do is you
write e to the the exponential of this
sum of these three operators the left to
right the middle you write that as a
repeated use the trotter product formula
so if I call this L middle and right I
write it as e to the L over N and it's
some big number it's a middle e to the
right that's me PPP and then try to
split that up that you can do you split
these separate traces because they're
already in this form but but then you
don't know what you've got anymore
because you don't have what you think
you have which is a copy of the original
problem because the original problem
when you've done this is not just the
original product so it takes work but
this was first done for the Heisenberg
model at least by Dyson myself and Barry
Simon after modeling us on Ehrlich and
Spencer who
assignment who showed the long-range
order for the classical bicycle rotor
but this was very hard very hard so
that's all I can tell you now
you can imagine they're just you just
can't do all the things you think you
can do it's so nice of you in this
classical world well you know eight
times B is the same thing as B times a
and the doesn't work that way
remote mobile precursor dependences
crystal state by changing from latest or
something a little bit disorder
physically yes but matically doesn't
work no here this this reflection
positivity method unfortunately really
depends on having strict geometric you
can't change the rules I mean it's very
inflexible you know we did we did we did
you mean the proof of that is the
crystallization with higher month yes we
did that's why I said you accept that
maybe what can what I could confuse
there was that you cannot just simply
reflect sort of vertices two vertices
because what's involved with
dimers you mean you're not allowed to
split a timer in half right anything you
can't can't do that so you have so you
if you're going to reflect you have to
take it as a unit not a point but four
points and all the things that can
happen on those four points which a lot
you can have this this like this this
you can have this and so on and that's
going to be a unit so the sort of the
hilbert space or thinking quantum
mechanically the hilbert space at a
given point is not just c2 anymore some
very high dimensional thing and so that
takes a little work and then you have to
follow this with a piles argument but it
does work am I being clear yeah okay
okay stick up for with it break and run
oh I'm sorry I went over
[Applause]